is one of the modern way to meet the
Queens can be declined and in today's
lecture we are going to witness one high
profile trap in this line from the white
perspective
[Music]
the critical position arises after the
following opening mortar
D4 D5 C4 E6 Knight to C3 and Knight to
F6 a starting point of the Queen's game
decline
whereafter flexible Knight to F3 and
Bishop to E7
white has three major alternatives
number one he can play the move Bishop
to G5 and enter into the main line
the second option is you can take on D5
and goes into the exchange variation
territory however there is a third Big
Time alternative here is G3 which no
wonder goes into the Catalan territory
okay the main line continues with Castle
on the king side white plate Bishop to
G2
and we have reached to the most
important Junction of this line
if black really choose the Tactical path
then he has to take the spawn on C4
known as the open Catalan territory
however as happened in many cases qgd
players are very solid and that's why
the second Big Time alternative here is
C6 putting a brick wall to this bishop
and going for a solid middle cave
okay white should Castle here and the
tricky platform is set right here guys
now if you look at the database here
there are two popular choices from the
Black
and amongst them I think Knight B to D7
is the accurate sequence
however there are more than 16 000 games
continue with B6 which leads to our
upcoming high profile trap
here white should start with Knight V5
and now you can see the drawback of the
black's last move he would love to
challenge this Knight with Knight B to
D7 but you cannot as the C6 Pawn hangs
well as per the database there are
roughly 450 games continue with Knight F
to D7 which leads to our first rapid
territory after this white is completely
winning and if you need a time you can
pause the video and find the sequence I
am showing you right now
first why take on D5 and it doesn't
matter however black recapture let's say
C captures D5
the killer blue happens here
did you see it
congratulations if you find the move
Knight captures D5
what a move
the point is after the forcing technical
sequence that is
e captures D5 Bishop captures D5
now the black Rook is hanging in the
corner so again black response is forced
he should take this Knight first and
after our recapturing
black can counter-attack our Rook with
Bishop to H3
so this is the best black can do in this
situation but look at the end after the
following transaction that is Bishop
captures eight
Bishop captures F1 and when white
recaptured this piece if you count the
material
not only white has come up with a
two-point Advantage but it also has a
bishop pair and as per the chess engine
this is completely winning at just 14th
move of the game
isn't that something special
okay so it is pretty clear that Knight F
to D7 leads to a disaster for black
so how about
first protecting this Pawn with Bishop
to B7 and now challenging this Knight
with Knight B to D7
doesn't it look good
well of course that has been played in
majority of the cases but I'm afraid
after White's next reply that is E4
black cannot play Knight to D7
why well that's the Trap guys and you
might want to try out that what is wrong
after this natural move which is as per
the database played in more than
thousand games
however just one move and black is
losing
the question is can you find it
well once again pause the video if you
need more time I'm showing right now
at this position white has a dazzling
reply
just look at this guys
Knight capture C6
boom
Another stunner
so time and time in this line what is
becoming a porno and the Big Time point
is when black take this piece we have
this nice sequence
e catches D5
it doesn't matter whether black captured
this Pawn or move the bishop back both
leads to the same trap so let's say e
captures D5 now we take back with the c
Pawn attacking the bishop and when this
bishop moves to the only Square namely
B7 we have a nice in between tactical
move D6
and after this no matter whatever black
plays he is going to lose a vital Pawn
in the opening
well the B7 Bishop is hanging so he has
to take on G2
but white has a nice internet so here
D captures E7 attacking the black queen
and when black take the spawn we can
safely recapture our peace back and if
you count the material
indeed white has come out as a complete
Pawn advantage
well don't forget to look at the results
here as white score is tremendous
foreign
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this
high profile trap in the closed Catalan
remember if your opponent played the
move B6 here then as I have shown in
this video
white can play the move Knight to E5 and
this leads to two amazing trap which you
definitely want to try out in your own
tournament practice
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and I
will meet you in my next episode very
soon
bye and take care